regional lockern oder überall voll auf
die bremse
kanzlerin merkel kritisiert den corona
kurs mancher bundesländer und denkt laut
über strengere vorgaben nach cairns
brief ich kann nicht atmen im fall des
getöteten george freund steht nun der
polizist vor gericht der ihm mit dem
knie die luft abschnürt und endlich
genug wasser unterm kiel spezialisten
aus aller welt machen den
containerriesen wieder flott der den
suezkanal blockierte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
an meiner seite ist norbert lehmann für
den sport ein schöner von mir die korona
zahlen steigen weiter und was tun bund
und länder streiten
die kanzlerin hat in der ard die
bundesländer erneut scharf gedrängt
versprochen es auch umzusetzen und vor
allem die notbremse zu beachten
doch viele länder sehen keinen grund für
einen kurswechsel
merkel kritisiert auch unionsregierte
länder deutlich vor allem die die
öffnungen planen das sei nicht das gebot
der stunde so die kanzlerin
und sie betont dass der bund auch ohne
die länder aktiv werden könnte sie sei
gesetzlich verpflichtet das
infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen
die reaktionen auf das merkelsche
machtwort fast weniger zusammen
demonstrativ macht ministerpräsident
tobias hans mit seiner öffnung strategie
weiter schnell test sollen hier im
saarland ab nächster woche die neue
eintrittskarte werden für kino theater
oder fitnessstudio wenn menschen
getestet sind also zusammenkommen einen
frischen tagesaktuellen schnelltest
haben ist es eben nicht so einfach ihnen
ihre grundrechte zu verwehren
hans hat das ganze saarland zur
modellregion erklärt weil die sieben
tage instanz noch unter 100 liegt und
hatte sich dafür von der kanzlerin
kritik eingefangen
die keine möglichkeit für lockerungen
sieht im gegenteil wir müssen mit einer
großen ernsthaftigkeit jetzt die
geeigneten maßnahmen einsetzen und
einige bundesländer tun das andere tun
es noch nicht und wenn das nicht der
fall ist ein sehr absehbarer zeit dann
muss ich überlegen das ist mein amt sei
dass meine verpflichtung wie kann man
das vielleicht auch bundeseinheitlich
und das vielleicht ich denke noch nach
ich bin noch nicht abschließend
entschieden aber eine möglichkeit ist
daneben auch das infektionsschutzgesetz
noch einmal anzupacken
auch nordrhein westfalen und berlin
werden von merkel kritisiert die
verabredete notbremse nicht gezogen zu
haben
beide länder chefs lassen das papier
es hilft uns auch nicht weiter wenn bund
und länder sich gegenseitig die
verantwortung zuschieben ich glaube
nicht dass es klug es aus dem kanzleramt
heraus jetzt einen länder bashing zu
betreiben unterstützung bekommt merkel
aus anderen bundesländern
ich sage sehr deutlich unsere
verantwortung ist auch dann wenn die
zahlen es nicht hergeben dann auch die
unangenehmen bereiche unserer
entscheidung auch umzusetzen
und da sagen ich sehe sehr klar dass
haben auch alle länder zu tun
es ist zu beginn der dritten
pandemiewelle ein machtkampf entstanden
zwischen merkel und manchen ländern
wer bestimmt über massnahmen wer hat das
sagen wenn reden und diskutieren nicht
weiterhilft kann dann die
bundesregierung das ruder übernehmen was
kann sie tun damit die länder
tatsächlich das beschlossene einheitlich
und konsequent umsetzen
das infektionsschutzgesetz böte den
rechtlichen rahmen
thomas konnte erklärt das
infektionsschutzgesetz das regelt
bundesweit wie ansteckende krankheiten
auch coop 19 zu bekämpfen sind dazu
erlaubt es den bundesländern
vorschriften zu erlassen
sie dürfen entscheiden was genau sie tun
der bund darf das nicht wie kann er die
länder zwingen zum beispiel die
vereinbarte notbremse zu ziehen
der bund könnte solche maßnahmen konkret
ins gesetz schreiben
sozusagen als oberste anordnung oder die
länder entmachten und gleich selbst
vorschriften erlassen
in jedem fall müsste er das
infektionsschutzgesetz ändern einer
solchen änderung müsste nach dem
bundestag auch der bundesrat zustimmen
und da könnten die länder sich
verweigern der bund er wäre also doch
wieder auf die länder angewiesen
ich konnte ja banerjee in berlin das
virus verbreitet sich munter weiter die
zeit drängt wie schnell könnte dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz geändert werden
eher theoretisch könnte man sowas sehr
schnell umsetzen wenn doch wirklich alle
wollten hören wir heute aus dem
bundestag und theoretisch könnte das
auch sehr weit gehen letzteres sagt ein
gutachten das
wolfgang schäuble heute an die
bundestags fraktionen weitergeleitet hat
da könnte der bund im
infektionsschutzgesetz sogar regeln für
schulen zum beispiel erlassen wie ja
normalerweise in länderhoheit fallen
allerdings gibt es da noch einige hürden
auf dem weg dahin
das innenministerium und das
justizministerium haben heute schon mal
gesagt wir haben das alles noch gar
nicht geprüft der regierungssprecher hat
heute gesagt jetzt sollten wir erstmal
die bestehenden regelungen um versetzen
und bund die länder müssten eben auch
noch zustimmen und danach sieht es
momentan erst mal nicht aus also es hört
sich nicht so an als ob sich die
kanzlerin mit ihrem härteren corona kurs
durchsetzen kann ja in die richtung
scheint es jetzt erst einmal nicht zu
gehen der chor der gegenstimmen hat ja
noch heute eine gewichtige stimme dazu
gewonnen armin laschet hat sich nochmal
erneut für diese flexible notbremse
ausgesprochen die die kanzlerin ja ganz
explizit ablehnt und er hat sich dafür
die rückendeckung geholt des cdu
präsidiums und in dem sitzen weitere
cdu-ministerpräsidenten zum beispiel
volker bouffier oder michael kretschmer
das sieht also momentan nicht so aus als
ob sich das ganze in die richtung
entwickeln würde
harter shutter und den sich die
kanzlerin wünscht die einschätzung
unserer hauptstadtkorrespondenten danke
hinterland von einem einheitlichen
rahmen im corona kampf kann bislang mich
wirklich die rede sein eher herrscht ein
kuddelmuddel jedes bundesland legt die
regeln so aus wie es sie für seine
regionen für richtig hält und auch bei
einer inzidenz von über 100 greift eben
nicht überall automatisch die eigentlich
abgemachte notbremse peter böhme und
daniela sonntag berichten
eine schlange vor dem laden da lacht das
kaufmanns herz gerade in diesen zeiten
die inzidenz heute morgen 78 5 in
warendorf deutlich unter 100 also
weiterhin einkaufen möglich mit termin
per click and meet klingt ist für uns
ein ganz wichtiges instrument im kontakt
zu einer kunst bleiben und auch umsätze
zu realisieren weil jede tür die offenes
wird auch genutzt in köln dagegen wurde
die notbremse gezogen
kein verkauf im laden mehr möglich die
inzidenz hierbei 132,2 die stadt will
kein risiko eingehen und zu haben ist ja
auch kanzlerin und ministerpräsidenten
beschlossen eigentlich denn in nrw
können auch kreise mit werten über 100
den termin einkauf weiter erlauben wenn
ein corona test konzept für die kunden
angeboten wird unverständnis einfach hin
und her und wir bürger sind dadurch
verunsichert was gilt heute was geht
morgen man weiß nicht ob man aus dem
lotto ist kommt wieder reingehen
also man sollte schon noch für
einheitliche linie verfolgen in weimar
in thüringen startete heute ein drei
tage versucht shoppen trotz inzidenz von
heute nur sehr knapp unter 100
voraussetzung ein frischer negativer
tests der bürgermeister sagt es muss für
die bevölkerung eine perspektive geben
ja weil die menschen nicht mehr können
wenn man wieder von einem lock down zum
nächsten hangelt und dinge noch mehr
verschärft man muss die rechnung mit dem
mensch faktor mensch machen und wir sind
keine maschinen und was man merkt wir
merken depressionen merken aggressionen
wir müssen alle lernen irgendwie mit dem
virus zu leben
wir müssen lösungen finden wie das gehen
kann ja auf dauer können wir nicht immer
auf und zu machen wird ist es ein hin
und her in den innenstädten im
nachbarkreis kann alles anders sein
schauen wir auf die infektionszahlen wie
immer zu beginn der woche liegen sie
wegen der geringeren tests am wochenende
etwas niedriger das robert koch institut
meldet neun 1872 neue ansteckungen
innerhalb eines tages das sind 2163 mehr
als vor einer woche
43 menschen starben in verbindung mit
cupid 19 die sieben tage inzidenz steigt
auf 134,4 deutlich höher liegt die
inzidenz bei unseren nachbarn frankreich
bei über 300 in immer mehr regionen
dürfen sich die menschen dort deshalb
nur noch in einem 10 km radius bewegen
läden sind ohnehin geschlossen
vor allem im großraum paris schlagen die
intensivmediziner alarm
thomas weiter berichtet
die krankenhäuser im großraum paris
schlagen alarm ihre intensivbetten sind
nahezu voll wenn die entwicklung so
weitergehe müsste man auswählen wen man
behandeln kann und wie nicht
wir werden über leben und tod
entscheiden das ist schwierig jeder
insbesondere in den vororten von paris
wie hier in santa und den ideen
infektionszahlen durch die decke eine
inzidenz von fast 800 fällen auf 100000
einwohner pro woche dts im center
menschen hier haben jobs die man nicht
in heimarbeit machen kann
sie arbeiten im kontakt mit anderen sie
benutzten öffentliche verkehrsmittel und
leben in kleinen wohnungen
es ist schwer einen kranken von seiner
familie zu isolieren schulen oder gar
das land wie in der ersten welle ganz
zuschließen lehnt die regierung bislang
ab der mann der alles entscheidet will
an seiner linie festhalten nur sehr wohl
regungen wir hatten recht am 29 januar
keine schließungen zu verhängen und wir
lagen richtig das öffentliche leben
etwas zu bremsen im verlauf der epidemie
ergreifen wir nützliche maßnahmen wenn
es an der zeit ist
emanuel macau will eine allzu
offensichtliche kurskorrektur vermeiden
stattdessen soll das impf tempo weiter
erhöht werden
aber es ist fraglich ob sich macau damit
über die zeit retten kann
direkt nach uns gibt's ein zdf spezial
lockerung oder lockdown und in der zdf-
heute- app finden sie alles rund um die
korona beschlüsse auch mehr dazu wie der
bund aktiver werden könnte um bundesweit
einheitliche regelungen durchzusetzen
zehn monate ist der gewaltsame tod des
amerikaners floyd jetzt her
beispiellos hatte nicht nur die usa
aufgewühlt
ab heute geht es vor gericht um die
frage nach der schuld
diese szene ging um die welt ein weißer
polizist drückt floyd bei einer
festnahme das knie in den hals neun
minuten lang obwohl der 46 jährige immer
wieder fleht er bekomme keine luft
sein tod löste eine internationale
protestwelle aus der polizist wurde
gefeuert jetzt drohen ihm bis zu 40
jahre haft
ines trams george clooneys familie und
seine anwälte knien sich hin erinnern
wollen sie an die rund neun minuten die
der weiße polizist derek quinn auf
lloyds hals kniete sie hoffen auf eine
lange haftstrafe
ein zeichen dass gewalt gegen schwarze
nicht ungestraft bleibt
wir müssen es nennen was es war es war
folter und der ex chefin muss für den
tod von jett floyd bestraft werden
minneapolis ende letzten jahres die
festnahme von george floyd
er stirbt unter dem knie des polizisten
der workshop in dem wird nun mord ohne
vorsatz vorgeworfen sein anwalt
argumentiert der einsatz des knies sei
gängige praxis freuds tod führt er
zurück auf drogen im blut und
vorerkrankung nicht auf erstickung es
gab keine blutergüsse an fleiß hals
nicht an der haut auch nicht darunter in
der muskelschicht es gibt keinen beleg
dass seine luftzufuhr eingeschränkt war
minneapolis ist nervös sorge vor einer
neuen welle der
bald eingerüstet das gericht 1000
polizisten und 2000 soldaten stehen
bereit
minneapolis erschütterten unruhen in den
nächten nach floyd es folgten
demonstrationen von ost nach west
die wut richtet sich bis heute vor allem
gegen die polizei gegen systemischen
rassismus wir haben zwei justizsysteme
in amerika eines für das schwarze und
eines für das weiße amerika das darf
nicht sein
heute ist der beginn von einem wandel
der lange überfällig ist
schuldig oder nicht schuldig in rund
vier wochen wird die zwölfköpfige jury
entscheiden auf den prozess schaut eine
stadt die gesamten usa ja die ganze welt
nachdem bisher blutigsten wochenende in
myanmar wird die internationale kritik
am militär lauter us-präsident beiden
und die bundesregierung kritisierten die
eskalation der gewalt scharf auch heute
protestierten in myanmar wieder mehrere
tausend demonstranten gegen das regime
erneut soll es tote gegeben haben am
samstag waren mehr als 100 menschen von
militär und polizei erschossen worden
tausende fliehen wurde gewalt wie hier
an der grenze zu thailand
großes aufatmen nicht nur in ägypten der
suez kanal kann wieder befahren werden
das containerschiff gewinn ist frei nach
tagelangem einsatz von baggern und
schleppern
der frachter hatte seit dienstag den
suezkanal blockiert auf beiden seiten
warteten zuletzt hunderte von schiffen
auf die weiterfahrt
der stau auf der wichtigen verbindung
zwischen asien und europa hat den
welthandel milliarden gekostet
oliver deuker
nach tagen des stillstandes ist das 400
meter lange containerschiff gegen
endlich wieder frei
dabei half auch eine
überdurchschnittlich hohe flut im
suezkanal bedingt durch den vollmond
vergangenen acht schiffe der ägyptischen
marine oder ein großer niederländischer
schlepper konnten das schiff mit hilfe
der flut zurückziehen und während der
anderen zeiten in denen die flug doch
nicht so hoch war
entfernten die bagger eine große menge
sand wie kanal bürger hat es geschafft
die beiden operationen erfolgreich zu
organisieren und diesen erfolg innerhalb
kurzer zeit zu erzielen
der suez kanal ist weltweit eine der
viel befahrenen strecken und verbindet
das mittelmeer und das rote meer
wegen der havarie derivativen verlor die
kanal behörde rund 14 millionen euro an
mautgebühren täglich nach
behördenangaben warten etwa 370 schiffe
auf ihre durchfahrt durch den 164
kilometer langen suez kanal darunter
auch 25 8,2 prozent des weltweiten
handels gehen durch den suezkanal wenn
hier der verkehr zum erliegen kommt hat
das große auswirkungen besonders auf die
öl und gas transporte vom arabischen
golf nach europa die beträchtlich sind
und damit kann dann auch der öl- und
gaspreis weltweit ansteigen
wie lange es dauern wird bis sich der
stau auflösen wird ist noch unklar
ägyptens präsident assisi bedankte sich
per twitter und voller stolz bei denen
die geholfen haben jetzt hoffen alle
dass der verkehr möglichst schnell
wieder anläuft und jetzt fußball norbert
die nationalmannschaft hat ihr soll
erstmal erfüllt und nur kann man so
sagen zweites spiel zweiter sieg und zum
zweiten mal die gleiche startelf und
zweimal null zu null gespielt es läuft
im löw team bei dieser wm qualifikation
einziger makel beim 1 0 erfolg gegen
rumänien gestern abend in bukarest die
vielen ungenutzten torchancen besser
gespielt aber auch glück gehabt so die
bilanz beim 1 0 sieg in rumänien da
passt von rüdiger zu herz erzählt sehr
schön aber mit seinem 15
länderspieltor den einzigen treffer in
bukarest ich glaube wir hätten früher
können hier den sack zumachen weil wir
hatten schon auch ein paar sehr gute
möglichkeiten zum 2 0
nicht nur der lateinisches von kim ich
auch weitere beste chancen kann die
deutsche elf nicht nutzen so dass
rumänien in der nachspielzeit noch
beinahe zum ausgleich gekommen wäre
noch in der nacht ist die mannschaft
zurückgekehrt nach düsseldorf im gepäck
den zweiten sieg im zweiten spiel der wm
qualifikation
vier tage nach seinem schweren sturz in
planica ist skispringer dangel andere
tante aus dem künstlichen koma erwacht
der norweger hat sich das schlüsselbein
gebrochen und die lunge leicht verletzt
er ist jetzt auf dem weg der besserung
so die ärzte nordamerikas basketball
meister los angeles findet zurück auf
die erfolgsspur vor allem dank des
deutschen nationalspielers dennis
schröder beim 96 93 erfolg der lakers
gegen orlando magic gehen 24 punkte
allein auf sein konto
die lakers ganz in weiß galten als klare
favoriten hier kennt hobby zum 44 36
doch orlando magic zeigte sich immer in
der lage das match ausgeglichen zu
gestalten
kiki zum 46 46
eine spiel entscheidende rolle fiel dem
deutschen nationalspieler dennis
schröder zu der sich mit 24 punkten als
bester werfer seines teams auszeichnete
am ende fehlten orlando nur drei punkte
zum ausgleich doch es blieb letztlich
beim knappen erfolg für glückliche
california und das war es auch schon vom
sport sie aber auch der basketball ist
ein bisschen traurig wenn keine
zuschauer da sind andere stimmung aber
jetzt haben wir noch was schönes das
wetter der frühling startet durch mit
sonne und temperaturen oft über 20 grad
die details hat gleich katja horneffer
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen noch einen richtig schönen
frühlingsabend bis morgen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das war ja
noch mal ein sehr wechselhaftes
wochenende in norddeutschland mit
graupel gewittern hagelschauern und
schneeschauern
die reste von diesem wechselhaften
wochenende die verließen uns heute
ostwärts und nur an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee blieben die wolken auch heute
nachmittag noch dicht und da bleibt es
auch in der nacht stärker bewölkt sonst
aber ist es meist sternenklar
unter den dichteren wolken an der küste
sinken die temperaturen auf acht oder
sieben grad kühler wird es hier im
nordhessischen bergland im rhein main
gebiet oder auch an der mosel mit vier
grad am kältesten aber ist es am
alpenrand da sinken die werte in den
leichten frost von minus 1 grad und
morgen erwarten uns dann
höchsttemperaturen die fast 20 grad über
diesen tiefs werten liegen am alpenrand
sind das dann um die 20 grad am
oberrhein aber auch im rhein main gebiet
geht es auf 24 grad rauf und nur an den
küsten von ost und nordsee bleibt es bei
12 bis 16 grad etwas kühler
die sonne könnte morgen astronomisch
gesehen genau zwölf stunden und 40
minuten am himmel stehen
sie können ja mal auf ihre uhr schauen
ob das auch klappt nur im nordosten sind
die wolkenfelder etwas dichter damals
nicht so ganz klappen am mittwoch gibt
es noch mal ganz ähnliches wird dabei
bis zu 26 grad ab gründonnerstag wird es
von norden etwas kälter in ab noch